[Music]
Kevin is 18. she is man does she have a
boyfriend yet I'm a man what's going on
okay
man don't make me nervous I'm just
asking you because that's the whole
thing yeah I don't know if it's a thing
okay
hey man I don't need to talk about that
I honestly don't know she hasn't talked
to me about it
you know I'm excited my little girl is
grown up she's uh about to embark on the
world of college life after the heart
household is now presenting itself she
likes creating she likes the idea of
producing developing acting you drop her
off at College absolutely absolutely
will you be the dad who cries oh I'm
probably gonna cry the baby you know I
got four kids though so it's not like
the households empty
look there's a photographer look watch a
picture
the father of four is bringing the funny
in the action-packed parody Die Hard 2
die harder on the Roku channel in the
eight episode series Kevin is on a quest
to become the greatest action hero of
all time but in a plot twist he finds
himself face to face with an enemy from
his past
nice to beef you you really want to be
an action star don't you do you I am the
next no no Kevin you want to be an
action I'm an action star wait a minute
you're trying to be an action and this
is like an actor who plays an active
star I've done action
that just didn't get released
John Cena and his long blonde wig joined
the cast playing a legendary Hollywood
stunt man do I make you uncomfortable
so you did all your stuff yeah real
everything everything me Tom Cruise
Jackie Chan Harrison
back up
[Music]